on dit souvent que l'une des des aspects
de l'intelligence artificielle c'est sa
capacité à évoluer au travers de langage
naturel et vous voyez bien il y a eu une
une comment dire
une une augmentation de la qualité la
reconnaissance vocale qui est beaucoup
plus importante et
euh le il y a deux choses que peut nous
procurer ce système de large langage
modè première c'est la capacité
d'interaction dans la communication
c'est des communications qui vont
devenir et qui sont en train de le
devenir d'après ce que je vois il y a un
petit retard sur la le français par
rapport à l'anglais mais qui est de
quelques semaines parce que les il y a
plus de de le corpus en anglais est plus
nombreux sur le sur internet mais
néanmoins je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué mais moi je parle littéralement
à gpt4 en conversation normale si vous
utilisez zoom et que vous demandez à
zoom de vous faire un compte-rendu à la
fin deun réunion il y avait une
vingtaine de person personne vous allez
voir la qualité du compte-rendu est
stupéfiante elle est vraiment de très
très bonne qualité et donc dans
l'interaction avec des services publics
ça va augmenter et puis l'autre
caractéristique des LLM c'est bah ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure c'est
d'être capable de souder des expériences
qui sont aujourd'hui exprimées en silo
c'est que si vous avez un service public
où on vous demande d'aller chercher des
données ou des documents qui sont dans
la la sphère sociale et puis dans la
sphère fiscale et cetera et bien le la
machine après priori est capable
d'intégrer tout ça et de le faire ça
dépend des
implémentations mais dans une forme de
respect de l'utilisation de vos données
personnelles alors je ne dis pas que
c'est ce qu'on va faire il y a tout un
tas de
de de de défis qu'il faudra dépasser
pour pouvoir faire ça mais si on en
avait la volonté on a une vraie
opportunité de rapprocher euh
l'expérience des services publics des
des citoyens où qui se trouve et à mon
sens c'est une opportunité qui est très
supérieure à celle du numérique parce
que la promesse du numérique c'était
celle-là au départ il y a 20 ans on
disait bah on va tout faire sur Internet
et ça va être super bien pour tout le
monde en réalité on a éloigné les gens
des services publics c'est le constat
qu'on peut faire à cet égard